[Applaudissements]
couple macron sur le champ de mars la
tour eiffel derrière eux et un discours
d'une dizaine de minutes du du président
réélu donc qui s'est dit fier de servir
à nouveau la france qu'ils aiment tant
la marseillaise est ce qu'on va écouter
tout de suite
[Applaudissements]
au
chômage
quand ça
ça
s'il en
est
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les jours huit mois
lee
oui
les mots
[Musique]
entendez monde
jc corso niçois
[Musique]
le lot
au bourget l'hémophile son journal
[Musique]
bourion
masson
montceau
que
[Musique]
si haut
voilà vous venez d'entendre cette
marseillaise chantée a cappella au champ
de mars devant les époux macron pour
élection d' emmanuel macron qui vient de
prononcer son discours où il a
effectivement remercier les
abstentionnistes ce qu'ils ont fait aux
barrages marine le pen tout
[Musique]